ladies
pop your body like this don't stop
though this
if you hear this from your man run
because the chances are high that this
cheapskate or slash
freeloader is just here for his own
benefit well no
you know it's good to avoid like cheap
skates or like freeloaders so
she's got poignant advice to help you
guys get away from that then i'm all for
it
so in today's video i'm going to give
you some things
that you can tell these men when they
come with these
cheap cliches let's start with number
one
i love independent women oh you know
what i love
i love strong masculine men i love
men who look after their women and treat
their woman
like a goddess there is nothing more
attractive than when a man
steps into his masculinity and really
looks
after his woman like a true gentleman
ah that's what i love when we want
independent women
it's not it's it doesn't mean that when
you're not gonna take care of her that's
not that's not what it means it means
that we don't want someone that's clingy
that's just i think that's what i get
i've never heard i love independent
women as
being seen as a bad thing no i never i
no i love dependent women
i love women who rely it's like it makes
no sense
it's like you didn't understand it the
like you took something that was said
you flip it some kind of way it's like i
was trying to make pancakes right here
all right my guy
i was making pancakes with the syrup and
everything all right
i was trying to do my thing here somehow
some way
you yank the plate out of my hands and
make an omelette with the [ __ ]
how i want to be with a woman who
doesn't depend on me
well that i believe is a responsibility
to both the man and the woman to make
sure
that that doesn't happen in the
relationship you just clowned him
earlier for saying he wants an
independent woman
but then you're saying we both have
responsibility to not be dependent on
the other
listen i don't want to be mad at you so
i'm not even going to try to mock you
but it's just hard for me to take you
seriously
when you contradict yourself in the very
same video which one is it
is he is he a goofball for wanting
independent woman or
should we depend on each other don't
know
it is what it is from the man's side he
has to
truly offer her an allowance so that she
contains her independence
she doesn't have to ask him for money
every time she wants something
so do you want her to be independent or
you don't
do you guys understand to what degree we
like you guys
to sit through some of the nonsense oh
this is hard bro
my ex-girlfriend only used me for my
money well then you know how it feels
for us
women when men only use us for sex
without committing to us
and without ever taking full
responsibility
by providing for us like a true
gentleman would do
well this is how we women feel used
how does that you're gonna be like yeah
well that's how you feel when
you're gonna sound bitter you know the
guy's like yeah all my exes
all my exes they use me for my money
says a lot about the people that you
date because the common denominator
is you and then you're gonna reply with
yeah well that's how you feel
when you sleep with a lady without
committing yeah
okay like the correlation remember when
you was at school
and it was on a page there was a bunch
of items
and another page there was another bunch
of items and you had to draw a trace
to see what item goes together well what
he proposed
and what you propose don't go together
i don't but anyways i digress if i pay
for today's date
will you pay the next what
oh if i have to pay for a date there
won't be a next
i said everything i said everything i
don't have anything to say about this
wow
today's episode is sponsored by blue
chew blue chew gives you the first
chewable with the same fda approved
active ingredients as
vagra or cialis it's prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor and wait in line
and it's even cheaper than a pharmacy
and they prepare it and ship it right to
you
in a discreet package you don't have to
worry about nobody coming through like
oh what's that
and you don't even have to leave your
house which during these times let's be
honest
so right now we got a special promo gwan
visit bluechew.com
and use promo code abba and get your
first shipment
free don't make any mistakes make the
right decision
you want to enhance your lives you don't
want to be like some of these couples
that you're watching in this video
then get on blue chew spice it up you
don't need to do any p-play
you don't need to be doing any water
squirting water sports none of that
blue chew is blue like water but it's
blue in a good way
if you want equality why should men be
paying hundred percent of the time
we want equal rights but that doesn't
mean that we are equals
get the [ __ ] out of here get out we're
done
we're good we're done i can't watch them
[Laughter]
you really want equality when it fits
you oh
i'm done
let's take black lives matter okay let's
take
my life matter i don't know because i
don't think anyways
while he made a taste i'll explain it
let me break it down to you
you're all for a movement yeah he's not
going to speak on this one
ever because he's already done but i'm
here he checked out
when she said ladies he checked out
i'm still here focus all right i got you
yeah when you have a movement any
movement it doesn't matter let's take
my life matter and at first they're good
you know they're really good
and you have these people these
extremists that are really
against your movement and you're like no
it's not like that it's not like that
and there's some people
in your movement that are being total
turds and it just gives more power to
these extremists and be like
see i'm right
because of that person right there there
that's what it is
all the people that you don't like all
the people that
are extremists like that are anti women
inside this and they look at this broad
and they're like
um that's the reason i'm like that you
know what i mean
bro you're not even religious don't even
hey man
i need somebody you try to use everybody
you know i have to go my head and
remember that chant you go
because you're expelling energy you're
just leaving it out there yeah i know
i get it so are you ready because
there's gonna be more
i know are you ready but i feel like
you're good now i feel like i've um
evolved i've steeled my mind i don't
think so
yeah iron fist iron mine
good luck you know you need those
there's a lot more
left in the video whoever's dating her
is definitely gonna need it we are not
biologically equal
men and women are built differently so
let's not pretend
that we are equals because that's just
the manipulation
men used and society use for the man's
benefit
women have far more disadvantages
financially
in society but also biologically this is
why we need to stop
talking about being equals and instead
focus
on what's fair you know i guess you
could quote all the ideas about like the
fact that women are graduating from
university more women are
starting out on their partners when you
account for the fact that women are
single and don't have any kids and all
that
they are often out warning the men in
their same workplaces so
you know i get what she's trying to say
and may have been true for a long time
but it's no longer
true in at least our parts of the world
and before anyone yells at me and go ah
why would you pick the it's not obscure
this channel is very popular i think uh
school of affluence is what it's called
and you know she's got 815
000 subscribers so i didn't that's
substantial you know that's a lot not
substantial
yeah so you know good for her and
yeah so you want me to pay your salary
for being with me
this is not a job this is not a salary
this is a very skewed way of looking at
it
it's like as if you are literally
passively aggressively calling a woman
to be a prostitute only very defensive
man
would say such a thing although what's
the difference between the allowance and
the
you're asking for an allowance you're
asking for an allowance
now first and foremost let's backtrack
let's backtrack this all right
let's backtrack this i don't think
there's really something wrong with
being a prostitute
now you ask for an allowance
i mean that's payment i'm paying
i mean there's something that you have
to do in return right what do you bring
to the table
are you seriously asking me this you
didn't even
[Applause]
you didn't even who do you think you are
wow wow i'm gonna have to nominate you
myself because
i gotta steal mine she can't get to she
can't trigger me
i got this i don't know if you're if
you're guys you guys already know i
don't need to sing nothing i don't need
to add nothing to this you already know
i know y'all watch this you get it it's
like you only win me because of the
money
well do you know us women we have to
constantly
wonder and worry about is he with me
because of the sex
or because of the looks or because i
cook so well
or clean so well or does his dirty
laundry
i don't know you're acting entitled
you know that men act entitled on a
daily basis
and it's fully normal they act entitled
when every day they are in bed
humping your leg wanting from you
wanting this from you
and they don't feel shy when they want
you to cook something to clean something
to run an errand to look after the kids
to do this to do that
now that's okay but as soon as a woman
is asking for this
one thing then we are these entitled
gold diggers do you see the unfairness
now ladies not all men are of course
like this they're a good man and they're
a bad man
but in this video i'm targeting
specifically the cheapskates
and truly some of the things that i
mentioned today they
really do use that as part of their
manipulation strategy
so basically ladies uh if you don't want
a freeloader be a freeloader yourself
wow that's the that's the video
that's it what we're saying right now is
just according to her
not women not just it's her her
a lot of the girls i know they'd be
looking at her and they'd be like oh
shake my head
that's not that ain't it that ain't it
but i guess they're not talking to them
i think at the end of the day the idea
of wanting someone in a
more comfortable life i'm not mad at
that i think it's it's quite normal to
want that and a lot of people do want
that
just the way she went about it was
really weird and then things that she
trashed and
it feel like her argument was like it
wasn't like
this is why it should be this way it was
more like
well they get away with it so i should
get away with it
you know what i'm saying when they were
saying like oh women are entitled
well men are entitled to it's like
you didn't disprove the fact that you're
entitled in some ways
it's like i go to court yeah and i go to
court and be like
yeah so you stole the property yeah but
this deal end up in jail
yes i think i think the main thing would
be like it would have been more helpful
i think to
just provide reasons for why this may be
conducive and why this is a good thing
rather than just being like
oh this i think oftentimes also people
just rely on biology all the time
to explain every phenomenon socialize if
a lot of our social norms haven't
changed over time in that regards
this whole thing about like uh well
women have this role not
zero because it's been like this well
you know at the same time i'm not
you know hitting you over the head with
a club and dragging you into a cave you
know what i'm saying like
things can change and evolve and there
can be some nuances discussion uh for
those of you
in 2020 by wat in 2021 uh for watching
your videos in 2020 wanted to learn
french
this is the perspective of the perfect
occasion for you to be able to learn
french
this is the learning french part of the
video
the sentence that we're learning today
is uh you
said nothing and in french
is targeted
you think you said something
but you said nothing meta yeah
i think it's just important to know we
don't live in the same world we used to
no we don't live in the world where
women make substantially less than ever
like in some countries that's still
reality yeah but in terms of a lot of
developed countries like women are
killing it and i think it's a good thing
yeah definitely graduating
definitely they're more educated they're
doing better after
after thing after after school so
considering all these things to hold
such
old-school views yeah it's still the
world we live in it's right
it's like you want your cake and you
want to eat it too yeah you want to use
past stuff to be like
oh my gosh you want to you want to use
this data says
you're eating yeah you know in fact a
lot of women who make lots of money say
that's an issue that they have
that almost all their prospects are
dudes who are substantially younger
yep so i'm like there seems to be a bit
of a hipaa
absolutely definitely i mean you want to
use someone that like you want to pick
you want a cherry pick
you want to pick and choose whatever you
want when it flews you i'm going to
choose to be a
cyst oh but now i'm going to use sex i'm
against that
because i don't like that part it's like
yo what are you doing what are you doing
just fine it's okay but ugh come on now
[Music]
yes
foreign